This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家过得怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在别处极不安全却足够坦诚的对话，而这一切都是在一位懂行的执业专业人士陪伴下进行的。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。这并不意味着你需要这样做，去听听吧。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWO%”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们常说，相信你的女性朋友。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。在《Look Back at it》播客节目中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down.
和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个与你探讨20多岁时最大的改变、时刻和人生转折点，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，让我们一起来剖析。
the psychology of our 20s. Today's episode is cutting right to the heart of so much of our fear and our doubt in our 20s. What if I regret the decisions I'm making right now? Or what if I regret the decisions I'm not making? At the heart of I think every DM I get, every discussion I have with you guys, the listeners, but with my friends, on dating, on jobs, on money, moving. health, whatever it is, at the center of all that is a deep fear of regret. There is like this vision we sometimes have in our mind of us looking back in 30 years,
20多岁时的心理。今天的节目将直击我们在20多岁时经历的许多恐惧和怀疑的核心。如果我对我现在做出的决定感到后悔怎么办？或者如果我对我没有做出的决定感到后悔怎么办？在我收到的每一条私信、我与你们这些听众以及朋友们关于约会、工作、金钱、搬家、健康等任何事情的每一次讨论的核心，都隐藏着一种对后悔的深深恐惧。在我们的脑海里有时会有这样一幅画面，那就是我们在30年后回首过去，
looking back at this moment and thinking, here it is. Like, this is the moment. This is the decision I can pinpoint for me for when it all went wrong. No doubt about it, this fear of like, is this the moment that I realized like I messed up in the future? That fear is so amplified in our 20s almost counterintuitively because we actually often have so many opportunities and so many doors open and so little room for regret at this point and so much future ahead of ourselves. But it's ironic, but it creates this constant pressure to not mess it all up despite just being at the start. So in this episode, I want to do a psychological deep dive into what actually drags.
回首这个时刻并心想，就是这里。就像，这就是那个时刻。这就是那个我可以精确指出的、一切开始出错的决定。毫无疑问，这种恐惧——比如这是我将来意识到自己搞砸了的时刻吗？这种恐惧在我们的20多岁时被急剧放大，几乎与直觉相反，因为在这个阶段，我们实际上往往有那么多的机会、那么多的门敞开着，几乎没有留下后悔的余地，而且前方还有那么多的未来。但具有讽刺意味的是，尽管我们才刚刚起步，它却产生了一种不能把一切搞砸的持续压力。所以在这一集中，我想对到底是什么引发了后悔进行一次心理学上的深度剖析，
regret, what people regret the most, how to manage it when it does show up. And why I actually think regret is one of the most motivating emotions we can actually access as we plan for our futures. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology of regret. When we talk about regret, what are we actually talking about? That's really important for us to understand. regret is sadness, it's disappointment, embarrassment, it's a sad mix of all those things. But I think it's mostly rooted in grief, to be honest. Grief over a life path we could have lived and the stories we could have made and the stories that we do make up about that life path, that it's better, that it's happier, that we didn't get to,
人们最后悔什么，当后悔出现时该如何应对，以及为什么我实际上认为后悔是我们在规划未来时可以调动的最具动力的情感之一。废话不多说，让我们进入后悔的心理学。当我们谈论后悔时，我们到底在谈论什么？这对我们来说非常重要，必须理解。后悔是悲伤、是失望、是尴尬，它是所有这些情绪的一种令人难过的混合体。但老实说，我认为它主要植根于悲伤。对我们本可以过上的一种生活路径的悲伤，对我们本可以创造的故事以及我们脑海中编造的关于那种生活路径的故事的悲伤，那种生活更好、更快乐、而我们却没有得到、
that we didn't get to have. This what if that is attached to every single regret, what if I'd done this, what if I hadn't, is probably the most important part of it. When we look at regret under like an emotional microscope, there are essentially two key ingredients. One of them is exactly what we're talking about. It's referred to as counterfactual thinking.
我们没能拥有的悲伤。这种与生俱来的“如果当初”伴随着每一个遗憾，如果我这样做了会怎样，如果我没有那样做会怎样，这可能是其中最重要的一部分。当我们把遗憾放在情感显微镜下观察时，本质上有两个关键要素。其中一个正是我们刚才所讨论的。它被称为反事实思维。
Counterfactual thinking is basically the brain's game of what if, you mentally go over an event, you imagine it a million different ways. One of them is obviously going to be better. There's the life that's actually happened and then there's the alternative reality that you play in your head. The versions where you said yes instead of no, you stayed instead of left, you spoke instead of staying quiet. Researchers call these counterfactuals, literally alternatives to the facts.
反事实思维基本上是大脑的一场“如果当初”的游戏，你在脑海中反反复复地回想一个事件，并想象它有一百万种不同的结局。其中一个结局显然会更好。现实中发生的生活与你在脑海中演绎的替代现实是两码事。在那些版本中，你说了“好”而不是“不”，你留下来而不是离开，你开口说话而不是保持沉默。研究人员将这些称为反事实，也就是对事实的字面替代。
They can go in two directions. In a downward counterfactual, you imagine how it could have been worse. Like, honestly, that could have gone horribly if I hadn't left when I did. That could have really been a disaster for me. In upward counterfactuals, though, you imagine a better outcome than the one you got. If only I'd revised properly, I could have passed that exam, and then I would have a better job than I do now, and I'd be making more money, and I'd be happier.
它们可以朝两个方向发展。在向下的反事实中，你想象事情本来可能会更糟。老实说，如果我当时没有离开，事情可能会变得糟糕透顶。那对我来说真的可能是一场灾难。然而，在向上的反事实中，你想象的结果会比你实际得到的更好。我要是当时好好复习了，本可以考过那门考试，那我就会有一份比现在更好的工作，赚更多的钱，也会更快乐。
Or if I'd only reached out to my friends more, maybe I'd be less lonely. Maybe my life would feel like it had more meaning. It's the upward ones that hurt. But counterfactuals aren't the only element here. You might think, you know, if the weather had been better, that holiday would have been amazing. And you feel a little bit annoyed and disappointed. That isn't regret. The missing piece here that we're seeing in these examples is self-blame.
或者我要是能多跟朋友联系一下，也许就不会那么孤独了。也许我的生活会更有意义。正是这些向上的反事实让人痛苦。但反事实并不是这里的唯一元素。你可能会想，如果天气再好一点，那个假期肯定会棒极了。你会感到有点恼火和失望。那并不是遗憾。我们在这些例子中看到的缺失的一环是自我指责。
You can have counterfactuals, but if you don't blame yourself, you don't have regret. Regret is what happens when you look at that better imagined outcome, that upward counterfactual, and you think, okay, that was on me. Like, that was my fault. Studies on this show, exactly that. Imagining a better outcome is one thing. When you tie that better outcome directly to your own actions, those evaluations become really bitter. and they become really painful. For example, a study from 2018 from researchers at the University of New England,
你可以有反事实的想法，但如果你不责怪自己，你就不会感到遗憾。当你看着那个想象中更好的结果，那个向上的反事实，然后心想，好吧，这怪我。就像，那是我的错，这时候就会产生遗憾。相关的研究也确切地表明了这一点。想象一个更好的结果是一回事。当你把这个更好的结果直接归咎于你自己的行动时，这些评估就会变得非常痛苦，
they looked at a sample of over 140 individuals, and they asked them to complete a survey about symptoms of depression, symptoms of anxiety. And then they also had them rank and rate past regret and regret intensity and how much they had to say, they had the opportunity to correct that situation. What the researchers found was that having greater regret did not correlate to being more depressed or unhappy.
并且变得非常煎熬。例如，新英格兰大学的研究人员在2018年进行的一项研究中，他们调查了140多名个人，要求他们完成一份关于抑郁症状和焦虑症状的调查问卷。然后，他们还让他们对过去的遗憾、遗憾的强度以及他们有多少机会去纠正这种情况进行排名和评分。研究人员发现，有更多的遗憾并不一定与更加沮丧或不快乐呈正相关。
Having greater regret that you blamed yourself for and that you felt like you could have done something about, that was where mental health went bad or depression really began to crop up more frequently in the participants. So what exactly do people regret the most? You may remember I did a full episode on this a while back titled The 20 Regrets People Have About Their 20s. I asked 5,000 people, what is the thing you regret the most about your 20s? And the biggest answers were, number one, focusing too much on romantic love or staying in an unsuitable relationship for too long.
那些你归咎于自己、并且觉得本可以做点什么却没做的遗憾，才是心理健康状况恶化或抑郁开始在参与者中更频繁地出现的地方。那么，人们究竟最遗憾什么？你可能还记得不久前我做过一整期关于这个主题的节目，标题是《人们对20多岁最后悔的20件事》。我问了5000个人，你对自己的20多岁最后悔的事情是什么？最大的几个答案是：第一，把太多精力放在浪漫爱情上，或者在不合适的恋爱关系中停留了太久。
number two worrying too much about what others thought of me number three not fighting more for friendships number four not investing sooner and then another big theme not going to college but equally going to college we heard a similar number for both go and listen to that full episode if you want the entire list of the full 20 because it's honestly so fascinating what we found but That was just for our 20s. That was just for this decade. If you were to ask a room full of people of all ages what they regret about life in general, some clear patterns do actually appear and become pretty consistent. Researchers from the University of Illinois published a meta-analysis of this very thing. They looked at 11 studies where people talked about regret and they analyzed it to figure out what the biggest themes were. they then ranked them in terms of most regret to least regret. Across all samples, all of these studies, the top six regrets were education number one,
第二，太在意别人对我的看法。第三，没有为友情付出更多努力。第四，没有更早进行投资。然后另一个主要主题是没有上大学，但同样地，去上大学的比例也不相上下，两者比例差不多。如果你想要完整的20条清单，可以去听听那一整期节目，因为老实说，我们的发现非常迷人。但这只是针对我们的20多岁。这只是这十年。如果你问一群各个年龄段的人，他们对整个人生有什么遗憾，一些清晰的模式确实会出现，并且变得相当一致。伊利诺伊大学的研究人员就此发表了一项元分析。他们查阅了11项人们谈论遗憾的研究，并对其进行了分析，以找出最大的主题，然后按遗憾最多到遗憾最少进行了排名。在所有的样本和所有这些研究中，前六大遗憾分别是教育排在第一位，
career, romance, parenting, identity, and then leisure. So above all else, education was interestingly, the thing that people regretted the most, mainly for not pursuing more of it. Daniel Pink, the author actually went further into this with his world regret survey. He turned this into a book, The Power of Regret, it was released in 2022. When he sorted through, and I think it was like 16,000 people's regrets from more than 100 countries, what he found was that it wasn't a specific thing. We might say education is the biggest, but actually what he found is there's categories,
职业、浪漫、育儿、身份认同，然后是休闲。因此，最重要的是，有趣的是，教育反而是人们最后悔的事情，主要是后悔没有在这方面深造。作家丹尼尔·平克实际上通过他的世界遗憾调查对这一点进行了更深入的研究。他把这些整理成了一本书——《遗憾的力量》，于2022年出版。当他筛选了来自100多个国家的约16000人的遗憾时，他发现这并不是某一件具体的事情。我们可能会说教育是最大的遗憾，但实际上他发现这里面是有分类的，
So four big categories of regrets. Foundation regrets, number one. That is where education comes down, comes to. So not building stability, not pursuing an education, not taking care of finances, your health. Foundation regrets, number one. Boldness regrets, number two, so not being brave enough, not taking chances. Moral regrets were number three, not acting in line with your values, doing something that you felt hurt other people. And number four was connection regrets.
因此，遗憾可以分为四大类。第一类，基石遗憾。这就是教育所归属的范畴。也就是没有建立稳定感，没有追求教育，没有理财，没有照顾好健康。基石遗憾排在第一位。第二类，勇敢遗憾，也就是不够勇敢，不敢冒险。第三类，道德遗憾，也就是行事不符合自己的价值观，做了让你觉得伤害了别人的事情。第四类是人脉遗憾，
so letting relationships wither or break down or not pursuing the person you really cared about. There's a phrase he says in the book that I love. Most people actually ended up regretting what they felt they had the greatest opportunity to change. They didn't regret the stuff that was totally out of their control. You know, the person who didn't love them back, the friend who just was never going to be on their team. But the moments where, you know, if they were honest, they had some power and they didn't use it, that was where a lot of the pain lay. They could have chased after that person.
也就是任由关系枯萎破裂，或者没有去追求你真正关心的人。他在书里说过一句话，我非常喜欢。大多数人最终对那些他们觉得自己最有能力改变的事情感到遗憾。他们并不后悔那些完全超出他们控制的事情。你知道的，那个不爱他们的人，那个从一开始就不会跟他们站在同一阵线的朋友。但那些他们说实话本可以发挥一些力量却没有去用的时刻，才是许多痛苦所在。他们本可以去追求那个人，
They could have bet on themselves. They could have started the business. They could have gone and gotten that education. That is the stuff that left the greatest impact. And I think that for people in their 20s, that's both the sobering and strangely empowering thought. It means that our regrets cluster around our sense of agency. And knowing that is actually really essential, and it's a vital takeaway, if one of your goals is to avoid regret in the future, I want to explain exactly why, after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
他们本可以孤注一掷，他们本可以创业，他们本可以去接受那种教育。正是这些事情留下了最深远的影响。我认为对于20多岁的人来说，这既是一个让人清醒、又奇迹般地赋予人力量的想法。这意味着我们的遗憾都围绕着我们的能动性而聚拢。了解这一点其实非常重要，这是一个至关重要的收获，如果你的目标之一是避免未来的遗憾，我将在短暂的休息后解释具体原因。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the sun. science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上担心的许多问题都是压力造成的。让自己经历一些磨难，
And you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即I-Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-Persent”。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在新一季的《The Girlfriends》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，怎么会发生这种事？警察似乎并不在乎，所以她们自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，才不。我发誓我将成为他的最后一个目标。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
他会得到应有的下场。请收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小金胸部的那一刻吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survive.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客节目中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
包括最近一期节目中，马克·拉蒙特·希尔滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的快克可卡因。坦白讲，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时都能聊一整天快克，只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，说到这儿，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在台面上了。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important. important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
我不认为对黑人来说有哪一年比这一年更重要。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听回放。欢迎收听我的新播客《狠狠学》
Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase. that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师卡尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、莱恩·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你们觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要？还是你们当好人只是因为害怕？因为兄弟，这是两种不同的动机。绝对是的。这也是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. I think in our 20s we definitely may have regrets. We may have a few regrets.
我希望你们能真正地做一个好人。加入我的新播客《狠狠学》，由我卡尔·盖恩斯与大家一起进行关于疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用。搜索《狠狠学》并立即收听。我想我们在20多岁时肯定会有遗憾。我们可能会有一些遗憾。
Like, you know, I regret how I treated that friend. I regret not taking that job. But most of how we experience regret is our future fear of it and wanting to ensure we have as little of it as possible. That is why I think personally. like people love those lists like the lists I was just talking about of like the greatest regrets we love them so much because they're like this guide right the irony is though the more you think about what you may or may not regret the more you analyze it the more you actually let that influence
比如，你知道的，我后悔那样对待那个朋友。我后悔没有接受那份工作。但我们体验到的遗憾，大多是我们对它的未来恐惧，以及希望确保我们将遗憾降到最低。这就是为什么我个人认为。人们如此喜欢那些列表，就像我刚才说的关于最大遗憾的列表，我们之所以如此喜爱它们，是因为它们就像一本指南，对吧？然而讽刺的是，你越是去想你可能会或可能不会后悔的事，你分析得越多，你就越实际上让这些影响
your decision making and the more likely you are actually going to make decisions that you regret more or not make a decision that you regret why is this why because it's artificially increasing the stakes for any and all decisions you make if you have this lingering fear that it's going to be the wrong one. And so that fear and that assessment of regret and whether this has potential for regret or not constantly interrupts your ability to trust your instincts. A lot of us live in what we call pre-regret. You haven't made the decision yet, but you're already imagining that it's the wrong one or how you might feel if you chose the wrong thing, you are lying in bed thinking already, you know, you haven't taken
你的决策，而你反而越有可能做出更多让你后悔的决定，或者不做某个你最终会后悔的决定。为什么会这样？因为这会人为地提高你所做任何及所有决策的风险，如果你挥之不去地担心这会是个错误的决定。因此，这种恐惧以及对遗憾的评估、这是否有潜力带来遗憾的评估，会不断打断你相信自己直觉的能力。我们很多人都活在所谓的“预先遗憾”中。你还没有做出决定，但你已经想象它是错误的，或者如果你选错了会是什么感觉，你躺在床上已经在思考了，你知道，你还没接受
the job, but if I take the job and I hate it, I'm never going to forgive myself. But if I don't take the job and it actually ends up being great, I'm never going to forgive myself either. So which one am I going to do? This one, that one, this one, that one. And then you basically do nothing. What's actually happening there with this scenario is that you haven't chosen the job yet. Nothing in your actual life has changed. You have no knowledge of whether it's going to be good or bad. You have made this pre-assessment or this pre-judgment
那份工作，但如果我接受了这份工作却又讨厌它，我将永远无法原谅自己。但如果我不接受这份工作，而它最终其实很棒，我也永远不会原谅自己。那我该怎么选？选这个，选那个，这个，那个。然后你基本上什么也没做。这种情况下真正发生的是，你还没有选择这份工作。你现实生活中的任何事情都没有改变。你不知道它是好是坏。你做出了这种事先评估或预先判断
that has influenced the decision before you've even given yourself a chance. You haven't taken the job or, you know, you haven't moved, you haven't quit, you haven't said the thing you want to say. But emotionally, you're already, and have already lived through all of these worst-case scenarios. The more you let yourself ruminate on these scenarios, on the worst case scenario, the more you believe that it's going to come true. This is a cognitive bias we call the availability heuristic. Essentially, we inaccurately judge how likely something is to happen simply based on how easy it is for us to recall.
这在你给自己一个机会之前就已经影响了决定。你没有接受这份工作，或者，你知道的，你没有搬家，你没有辞职，你没有说出你想说的话。但在情感上，你已经经历并活过了所有这些最坏的情况。你越是让自己沉浸在这些情境中，沉浸在最坏的情况中，你就越相信它会成真。这是一种我们称之为“可得性启发”的认知偏差。本质上，我们仅仅根据某件事对我们来说有多容易回忆起，来不准确地判断它发生的可能性。
and of course the emotionally salient disaster regret scenarios your brain is cooking up for you. They are going to be the easiest ones to recall. They are going to be the most prominent because they are the most emotional. The danger here is that you spend so long thinking again or trying to outthink regret, you do not move, you do not act. This is the paradox of the perfect decision. the more you chase a perfect decision, one that is, I guess, that guarantees like permanent emotional comfort, the harder it becomes to do or to choose anything
当然，那些情绪突出的灾难遗憾场景是你的大脑为你炮制的。它们将是最容易被想起的。它们将是最显著的，因为它们最情绪化。这里的危险在于，你花了太长时间再次思考或试图超越遗憾，你没有迈出脚步，你没有行动。这就是完美决策的悖论。你越是追逐完美的决定，那种保证能带来永久情感安慰的决定，你就越难去做或选择任何事情
at all because the worst case scenario, the regret-based scenarios, all those things your brain creates, like you cannot release them. I've been there so many times. You tell yourself you're just being careful. You tell yourself like, hey, I'm just waiting, I'm just waiting till I'm 93% sure when you could have made the decision when you were 51% sure. And you would have still felt as conflicted as you do now. And I'm sorry to be the bearer of bad news, but that the perfect decision doesn't exist anyways. 100% certainty only exists in hindsight.
因为最坏的情况，基于遗憾的情景，所有你大脑创造的东西，你就是无法摆脱它们。我也曾多次经历过。你告诉自己你只是在小心谨慎。你告诉自己，嘿，我只是在等，我只是在等到我有93%的把握，而其实你完全可以在只有51%把握的时候做出决定。那时你感到的纠结程度其实跟现在一样。很抱歉带来这个坏消息，但完美的决定无论如何都是不存在的。100%的确定性只存在于事后诸葛亮中。
Every real choice comes with tradeoffs. It comes with losses. It comes with gains as well. Trying to find the perfect option that is never going to hurt you. there's never going to give you regret, means you are going to stay in situations that you have outgrown. What I can say, though, is that even if the worst case scenario happens, it is often never as bad as we emotionally predict it to be. This is where effective forecasting comes in.
每一个真正的选择都伴随着权衡。它伴随着损失。它也伴随着收获。试图找到那个永远不会伤害你、永远不会带给你遗憾的完美选项，意味着你将永远停留在那些你已经超越的境况中。不过，我能说的是，即使最坏的情况发生了，它通常也远没有我们在情绪上预测的那么糟糕。这就是效果预测派上用场的地方。
It is the human habit of trying to predict how we feel in the future and getting it very, very wrong. When it comes to regret, our forecasts are usually wildly pessimistic. So we end up organizing our whole lives around an emotion we're probably not actually going to feel. We don't necessarily even fear regret. We fear an exaggerated imagined version of regret that is a projection of our deep fears and insecurities and everything going wrong when actually that very rarely happens. What we also know from the research is that the easiest way, again, to avoid regret, is to actually take any kind of action in any direction, even if you don't know for sure it's
这是人类试图预测我们未来感觉却错得离谱的习惯。当涉及到遗憾时，我们的预测通常是极其悲观的。所以我们最终围绕着一种我们可能实际上并不会感受到的情绪来安排我们的整个生活。我们不一定真的害怕遗憾。我们害怕的是被夸大的、想象中的遗憾版本，这是我们内心深处的恐惧、不安全感以及一切出错的投射，而实际上这种情况极少发生。从研究中我们还了解到，再次强调，避免遗憾最简单的方法，就是实际朝任何方向采取任何行动，即使你并不确信它是
going to be the right one. Take, for example, the 1997 paper on regret and self-discrepancy theory. What researchers found in their research assessing the regrets of thousands of people is that 24% of regrets were about things people did do, 76% of regrets were about the things they didn't do. What they realized is that there are two types regrets, action regrets and inaction regrets. Inaction regrets, they are far more common. So if you want to avoid regret overthinking it is not going to do anything, making a decision will. Make any decision, any decision at all, the only way out of the paradox isn't to lower your standards so much as to tell yourself the truth. There is no decision that will absolutely protect me from regret.
会是正确的。以1997年关于遗憾与自我差异理论的论文为例。研究人员在评估数千人遗憾的研究中发现，24%的遗憾是关于人们做了的事，76%的遗憾是关于人们没有做的事。他们意识到有两种类型的遗憾，行动遗憾和不作为遗憾。不作为遗憾要常见得多。所以如果你想避免遗憾，过度思考是没有任何作用的，做决定才会有用。做出任何决定，任何决定都可以，打破悖论的唯一方法不是把你的标准降得太低，而是对自己说实话。没有任何一个决定能绝对保护我不受遗憾的伤害。
at some point I will wish I had known what I do know now, but if I make a choice, my chances of that are going to be a lot less. So if you are currently in a state of regret, you regret something you did or didn't choose in the past, I also want you to recognize that the option you're currently living in is the real one, and it is full colour and it is complicated and it has good days and bad days and awkward conversations and admin and loneliness and traffic. That is the real thing that is happening to you. The option you didn't choose that you are torturing yourself with believing that it was the better one, that only lives in your head. And what it is in your head is not real. As much as what hasn't happened yet can be convincingly very, very terrifying,
在某个时刻，我会希望自己当时就知道现在所知道的，但如果我做出了选择，这种几率就会小很多。所以如果你目前处于遗憾的状态，你对过去做过或没有选择的事情感到遗憾，我也希望你认识到，你目前生活的选项是真实存在的，它是丰富多彩的、复杂的，有美好的一天也有糟糕的一天，有尴尬的对话、行政杂务、孤独和交通堵塞。那是真正发生在你身上的事情。你没有选择的那个选项，那个你一直在折磨自己、坚信它更好的选项，只存在于你的脑海中。而它在你脑海中的样子并不是真实的。正如尚未发生的事情可以让人信服地感到非常非常可怕一样，
what we expected to happen that didn't can be convincingly flawless. You see yourself in that other city with instant friends in a cool flat and you're not struggling with paperwork or a visa and you're not missing home or you're not missing your dog. You see yourself in the other relationship and the relationship you tried one more time to make work and you're laughing now and you're not arguing about money anymore. Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. You're comparing reality, your messy real life to something that is just completely like, like, just buffed of all badness. And you think that those things are equally probable and you think that the one that you're imagining could have happened.
我们期望发生却没有发生的事情可以让人信服地毫无瑕疵。你看到自己在另一个城市，瞬间拥有了朋友，住在一间很酷的公寓里，你不用为文件或签证苦恼，你没有想念家，也没有想念你的狗。你看到自己在另一段关系中，那是你多尝试了一次才得以维系的感情，你现在正在笑，你不再为钱争吵。等等，等等。你在拿现实生活，你那混乱的现实生活，去和一个完全被抹去了所有坏处的东西相提并论。你认为这些东西发生的概率是一样的，你认为你想象中本可能发生的那种生活
That is not true. No one's life is perfect the way that we are imagining it. I think another useful reframe to stop fearing regret is to also understand when in our lives regret has maybe actually saved us. We've mostly talked about how regret hurts. I don't hear people talk about how it can protect. you. You regret missing that travel opportunity with your friends. You know what that means? You're not going to miss out again. You regret how you treated that friend when you were 21, that you ghosted them,
是不真实的。没有人的生活像我们想象的那样完美。我认为另一个停止害怕遗憾的有用重构，也是要理解在我们生命中的什么时候，遗憾其实曾经拯救过我们。我们大多在谈论遗憾是如何带来伤害的。我没听人谈论过它如何能保护你。你后悔错过了和朋友一起旅行的机会。你知道这意味着什么吗？你以后不会再错过了。你后悔21岁时如何对待那个朋友，你ghost了他们（对他们冷暴力），
that you didn't come through with your promises. That self-blame and pain is going to make you a better friend in the future. You regret not spending more time with your grandparents. As your parents get older, you're not going to make the same mistake. In that way, regret functions a bit like a bruise on your moral skin. You bump up against a line you didn't know was there and it hurts and afterwards, you remember that, you move a little bit more carefully. Don't keep walking into the same sharp corner in quite the same way. It's not that you never make mistakes again, obviously you do, but you rarely make the exact same one at the same level because regret has taught you an important lesson. When you are tempted to see your regrets as proof that you're a disaster or that something has
你没有兑现承诺。那种自我责备和痛苦会让你在未来成为一个更好的朋友。你后悔没有花更多的时间陪祖父母。随着父母年龄增长，你不会再犯同样的错误。从这个意义上说，遗憾有点像你道德皮肤上的瘀伤。你撞上了你原本不知道在那里的底线，它很痛，在那之后，你记住了，你走得更加小心了。不要再以完全相同的方式撞向同一个尖角。这并不是说你再也不会犯错了，显然你还是会，但你很少会以同样的程度犯完全相同的错误，因为遗憾给你上了一课。当你忍不住把遗憾视为自己是一场灾难或某些事情已经
failed, it's worth zooming out. Some of the qualities you like most about yourself now, the care you take with people, the risks, the risk mindset you have are probably shaped by very old painful moments where you didn't know. Regret hurts, it's also been steering you away from becoming a version of yourself. You probably wouldn't be able to live with either. Now, there are some regrets for which this is simply not. not going to make us feel better. Nothing came from it. You didn't learn anything. It's made your life worse. Sadly, that is the case sometimes. Then it might be simply worth looking at how we can live with the facts of what happened. One of the hardest but most important cognitive skills
失败的证明时，不妨放宽视野。现在你最喜欢的自己的一些特质，你对待人们的细心、风险意识，可能都是由那些你还懵懂无知的古老痛苦时刻塑造的。遗憾是痛苦的，但它也一直在引导你避开那个你可能根本无法与之共存的自己。现在，有些遗憾对我们来说根本无法让我们感觉好受一些。从中什么也没有得到。你什么也没学到。它让你的生活变得更糟。可悲的是，有时情况确实如此。那么，也许只需看看我们如何能够接受已经发生的事实即可。最困难但最重要的认知技能之一
I think we can master, and I'm yet to master it. I'm being optimistic. I wish I could. But it's acceptance. Accepting that this happened. Regret will happen. such as the flow and intricacies of life and not having, not being able to predict the future. You don't have to put a positive spin on it. You don't have to turn it into an opportunity. But you have to be willing to acknowledge that, yeah, it happened and there's nothing, you can change it. And you can go forward anyways. I'm not going to ignore the fact that I don't like it.
我认为我们可以掌握，但我自己还没掌握。我很乐观。我希望我能掌握。但那就是接受。接受这已经发生。遗憾会发生。这就是生活的流转与错综复杂，以及无法预测未来的结果。你不必给它粉饰太平。你不必把它变成一个机会。但你必须愿意承认，是的，事情已经发生了，你什么也改变不了。无论如何你都可以继续前行。我不会忽视我不喜欢这个事实。
I wish it were different. But this is the reality that I'm facing. As long as you are mentally replaying the past trying to get a different outcome, you stay locked in a kind of mental argument with yourself that you're never going to win and you will never be able to move forward from. Regret in that moment just paralyzes you further. It reduces any ability you have to change. It's also important to note that what's happening there in that moment where you just ruminate on everything you could have done differently is its own kind of cognitive bias. It's called hindsight bias. The tendency to believe
我希望它能有所不同。但这正是我所面临的现实。只要你在脑海中不断重播过去，试图得到一个不同的结果，你就一直锁定在一种永远无法赢得的与自己的精神争论中，你也永远无法从中释怀。那一刻的遗憾只会让你进一步瘫痪。它会削弱你做出改变的任何能力。同样重要的是要注意，在你不断反刍所有你本可以做出的不同选择的那一刻，正在发生的事情本身就是一种认知偏差。这被称为“后见之明偏误”。也就是这种倾向：认为
that past actions should have been obvious or avoidable, given what you know now. We all know that's not true. For every scenario your brain may have cooked up for you of how this could have gone good or bad, and for all that predictive value you think your brain has, there's always going to be an option that you didn't think of, and it's probably the option that happened. Because, again, you can't predict the future. And that is why radical self-compassion is so important.
过去的行动本应该是显而易见或可以避免的，鉴于你现在所知道的一切。我们都知道这不是真的。对于你大脑可能为你炮制的关于这件事可能变好或变坏的每一个场景，以及为了你认为你大脑拥有的所有预测价值，总会有连你想都没想过的选项，而那很可能是真正发生的选项。因为，再次说明，你无法预测未来。这就是为什么彻底的自我同情如此重要。
You've made a mistake, you have a deep regret about something, you're not sure if you can move past it. Having radical self-compassion in that moment is not an attempt to excuse the behavior or to change it. It's just the tone you take with yourself when you think back on it. When I think about regrets I have, I always go back to the Professor Kristen Neff's model of self-compassion. She defines it as comprising of three components. Self-kindness, responding to personal failure with care rather than harsh judgment. common humanity, recognizing that anybody else could have made the same mistake or have a similar
你犯了一个错误，你对某事深感遗憾，你不确定自己是否能走出来。在那一刻拥有彻底的自我同情，并不是为了替行为辩护或去改变它。它只是你在回想时对自己的语气。每当我想到自己的遗憾时，我总是会回到克里斯汀·内夫教授的自我同情模型。她将其定义为包含三个组成部分。自我关怀，用关爱而不是严厉的批判来回应个人失败。共同人性，认识到其他任何人也都可能犯过同样的错误或有类似的
regret to you and what you're experiencing, and also mindfulness, just holding painful thoughts and emotions in balanced awareness with other more positive thoughts, not over-identifying with them, not saying that because I made this mistake, because I didn't make this choice, this is who I am for the rest of my life, just acknowledging that they are part of your life the way many more magical parts are as well. Importantly, this research consistently shows having that kind of respect and relationship to regret
遗憾，这与你的经历并无二致，还有正念，只是将痛苦的想法和情感与其它更积极的想法保持平衡的觉知，不过度认同它们，不认为因为我犯了这个错误，因为我没有做出这个选择，我这一生就定格于此了，只是承认它们是生命的一部分，正如许多更神奇的部分一样。重要的是，这项研究始终表明，拥有这种对遗憾的尊重和关系
doesn't reduce accountability, it doesn't reduce moral standards. It actually means you're more likely to take responsibility, you're more likely to apologize, to want to change. And again, it actually reduces future likelihood of encountering a similar situation, acting in the same way, and doubling your regret. As we wrap up this episode on the psychology of regret, I want to say, it is impossible to live without regret. It is one of those emotional scars we all get as humans. The same as heartbreak,
并不会减少责任感，不会降低道德标准。它实际上意味着你更有可能承担责任，你更有可能道歉，想要改变。再说一次，它实际上降低了未来遇到类似情境、以同样方式行事并让遗憾翻倍的可能性。在我们结束关于遗憾心理学的这一集时，我想说，人是无法在没有遗憾的情况下生活的。它是我们作为人类都会得到的那些情感伤疤之一，就像心碎一样，
the same as grief. It also reflects the fact that we get choices and that we have agency and that we have things that we care about. I've been trying to do this thing lately for every emotional thing or event I fear or that I think is bad or that I don't enjoy like regret. I imagine what life would be like without it. Like if regret was an emotion, we just couldn't feel or we could opt out of or we didn't have access to, would that be better? And honestly, I actually think the world would be way worse. People would be terrible to each other because they wouldn't have regrets about it. And again, I think we wouldn't have the agency we have over our lives now is a worthy price to me, you know, that I am able to
就像悲伤一样。它也反映了这样一个事实：我们拥有选择权，我们拥有能动性，我们有我们在乎的事物。我最近一直在尝试这样一件事，对于我害怕的、或者我认为糟糕的、或者我不喜欢的所有情感事物或事件，比如遗憾。我想象一下如果没有它，生活会是什么样。就像如果遗憾是一种我们根本无法感受、或者我们可以选择退出、或者我们无法触及的情感，那会更好吗？老实说，我实际上认为世界会变得更糟糕。人们会对彼此非常恶劣，因为他们不会对此感到遗憾。再说一次，我认为我们对生活不再拥有现在的这种能动性对我来说是一个值得的代价，你知道的，我能够
regret because I have choices. If I didn't regret, I wouldn't have choices and I wouldn't have the freedom to choose and that in itself is a blessing. So that is my final takeaway message from this episode, not to be, you know, not to be too toxicly positive, but yeah, how can we see regret as maybe an asset rather than a weakness at times. If you enjoyed this episode, I would really recommend you go and listen to our episode on the 20 biggest regrets people have in their 20s. That full list is incredible and so much effort went into that episode and there's so much to learn. Especially if you like knowing what kind of themes regret clusters around in order to avoid it yourself. If you have made it this far as well, thank you for listening.
感到遗憾，是因为我有选择。如果我不遗憾，我就没有选择，我也没有选择的自由，这本身就是一种祝福。所以这就是我从这一集得到的最终核心信息，不是为了显得，你知道的，不是为了显得过于盲目乐观，但对有时我们如何能将遗憾视为一种资产而不是弱点。如果你喜欢这一集，我强烈建议你去听听我们关于“人们在20多岁时最大的20个遗憾”的那集节目。那个完整的列表令人难以置信，那一集投入了大量的精力，有太多的东西可以学习。特别是如果你喜欢了解遗憾围绕着什么样的主题聚集，以便自己去避免它。如果你也听到了这里，谢谢你的收听。
you have made it to our secret question of the episode. What's something you actually thought you would regret, but didn't? Leave a comment down below. And as always, thanks for tuning in. Thank you to our researcher Libby Colbert for her contributions to this episode. Make sure you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast and subscribe wherever you are listening right now. Until next time, be safe, be kind. Be gentle with yourself. Thank you for tuning in. We will talk very, very soon.
你已经听到了我们这一集的秘密问题。有什么事是你其实以为自己会后悔，但却没有后悔的？在下方留言。和往常一样，感谢收听。感谢我们的研究员莉比·科尔伯特对本集的贡献。确保在Instagram上关注我们@That Psychology Podcast，并在你现在收听的任何地方订阅。下次见前，注意安全，保持善良。对自己温柔一点。感谢收听。我们很快就会再聊。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
2%。这是旁边有自动扶梯时仍会选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等人对话，带你抛开统治健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾深信种子油天生会引发炎症。我们弄错了。我们在这个世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的T-W-O-Persent。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你在玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。
And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific. con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
法则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这新一季的《闺蜜》中……天啊，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们约会了同一个多产的骗子。我觉得自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，畅谈80年代的快克毒品。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊快克，但只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条主线了。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardaway with me, your host, and your favorite things. Careers, Care Games.
是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing
为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，
and we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person
而我们却仍在追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人世间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人
because you're afraid because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth,
是因为你感到害怕？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。确实如此。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们在我的新播客《learn the hard way》中就治愈、成长、
fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, search Learn the Hardway and listen now. Hey, what's good, y'all? you're listening to Learn the Hardway
父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的I-Heart Radio应用，搜索Learn the Hardway并立即收听。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》
with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability
主持人是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，
that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
并不意味着你需要这么做。在I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《learn the hard way》。2%。这是旁边有自动扶梯时仍会选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的TWO.%当一群女性发现她们约会了同一个多产的骗子时，她们决定自己动手。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast For 1979, that was a big moment for me 84 was big to me I'm Sam J and I'm Alex English
我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中，对于1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻，84年对我也很重要。我是山姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利希。
Each episode we pick a year unpack what went down And try to make sense of how we survived it With our friends, fellow comedians and favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s 84 was a wild year I don't think there's a more important year for black people Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app
每一集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何与朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家（比如聊80年代的马克·拉蒙特·希尔）一起挺过来的。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这更重要的黑人年份了。在IHeart Radio应用上收听《Look Back at it》
Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。